[GUITAR MUSIC]
LAURA LING: What are
you cooking today?
JP REYES: I'm going to
make a popcorn shrimp.
What I did was just bread it in
some panko and some seasonings.
LAURA LING: Sounds delicious.
JP REYES: Oh, yeah.
LAURA LING: What he's cooking
actually isn't shrimp at all.
It's a meatless
product made in a lab
by New Wave Foods, a biotech
startup founded by Dominique
Barnes and Michelle Wolf.
Tell me how you conceived of
this idea to make fake shrimp.
DOMINIQUE BARNES:
Shrimp is the number one
consumed seafood in the US.
You know, this is a product
that we enjoy eating
and many other people do too,
but the way we're getting it
now isn't sustainable.
LAURA LING: Did you know that
38% of the world's mangroves
have been destroyed to
create shrimp farms?
That even one hamburger
wastes more water
than two months of showering?
That agriculture contributes
nearly one quarter
of global greenhouse
gas emissions?
Our seemingly insatiable
appetite for meat
is having a devastating
impact on the environment.
But some are betting that
biotechnology will offer
a sustainable alternative.
Wow, so this really
does look like shrimp!
I'm impressed.
What has gone into this process?
MICHELLE WOLF:
What you're seeing
is a combination of different
plant and algae ingredients
and then our
proprietary process,
which really gives
it the bounce-back
that a lot of
people mention makes
it taste a lot like shrimp.
LAURA LING: Can I handle it?
MICHELLE WOLF: Yeah, totally.
If you take one up
and smell it you
should get sort of a
shrimpy-type smell.
LAURA LING: Yeah, it's
not quite as pungent
which is not a bad thing.
MICHELLE WOLF: I know.
LAURA LING: Does your product
have the same nutritional
value?
DOMINIQUE BARNES:
Our products will
have very similar nutritional
value as far as having
high protein, low fat.
Because they're made
out of plants and algae,
it'll be zero
cholesterol, and even
if you have a shellfish
allergy, you will most likely
be able to consume
our product because we
don't have that same component.
LAURA LING: New
Wave Foods is part
of a growing movement of
biotech companies creating
meat alternatives.
Others include
Memphis Meats, which
grows real meat from cloned
pig, cow, and chicken cells.
Impossible Foods plans to
create a plant-based burger
with the same taste, texture,
and appearance of real ground
beef.
And a company called Clara
Foods makes vegan egg whites out
of yeast.
Where do you see
the future of food?
MICHELLE WOLF: What
it comes down to is
taste-- that we
can, you know, apply
all these amazing processes,
but if it doesn't taste amazing,
and consumers aren't
going to accept it.
LAURA LING: JP
Reyes, a vegan chef
at the Google offices
in San Francisco,
has been one of the first to
incorporate New Wave shrimp
into his dishes.
JP REYES: At Google,
we have a lot
of sensitivities, allergies,
diet restrictions--
so it's nice that we're able
to offer a shrimp alternative.
LAURA LING: All
right, Chef JP, so I
brought my dad to
this taste test-- he
is the ultimate seafood lover.
JP REYES: All right.
LAURA LING: OK right.
Ready, Dad?
DOUG LING: I'm ready.
LAURA LING: I think it's yummy.
You can tell it's
not real shrimp?
DOUG LING: No, I can't.
Tastes a little like scallop.
LAURA LING: Oh, okay.
So did it meet the Doug
Ling seafood-loving test?
DOUG LING: Very nice.
LAURA LING: Do you
think that we are
sort of entering a new era when
it comes to food technology?
DOMINIQUE BARNES: It does
definitely feel that way.
And I think it's going to take
a lot of these great ideas that
are coming to market to help
solve some of the problems
that we see in our
food supply chain.
And our ultimate goals
is really to continue
to create delicious
food that's good for you
and the environment
LAURA LING: Are you curious to
try these meat alternatives?
Let us know in the
comments below.
And to see how ugly food
can transform our planet,
watch this next video.
To prepare for tonight's
event, Chef Pesha Perlsweig
visited various
markets to see what
ingredients she could transform
into a six course dinner.
MAN: She finds ingredients
that are going to go to waste
and then she turns it into these
intricate, amazing, interesting
dishes that people love.
LAURA LING: Thank you for
watching Seeker Stories.
Please subscribe to see
new videos every week.